so it took a long time for nimona to get
here it's here now and I'm very happy
that it's here now but I want to know
what was it about this project that kind
of Drew the two of you to it when it was
being redeveloped yeah I mean the the
simple answer is is nimona herself it
was that character
um it was really stepping back and
getting to see how you know it was
amazing she's this confident
Unapologetic in your face punk rock sort
of uh you know strong female lead which
you don't get a chance to see a lot
um but Underneath It All you feel that
that emotion and and frustration and and
pain that makes her real and and you
really we really start to feel that idea
of this this character who just wanted
to be seen right who just wanted someone
to get to know who they were from who
they were and not judge based on past
stories or expectations and it just
became super clear that once we embraced
that idea
the rest of the movie started to fall
into place The Narrative of the other
characters
um you know the the way you know people
around the studio would just connect
with that especially in a lot of sort of
unrepresented communities like the lgbtq
plus I mean there was just this feeling
this Groundswell of being seen and being
uh expressed in media which I think is
so powerful and so important uh and it
makes you not necessarily feel alone and
even though what we were telling this
very specific story I think the exciting
thing for us we started to realize the
more we were leaning into that and
getting these stories and and trying to
be truthful and how we're depicting them
the more Universal that became that the
more that you know she actually
represented this this connection to
anybody who's felt misunderstood or
different which I think most people
regardless of of what their background
is can can relate to that and
that's I think when we knew we had
something and and uh we just kept
building off of that yeah I mean that
said we had something and then it was
killed
right and it was shut down you can't
fight money
uh but no we had you know so many people
just say to us how important this film
would have meant to them as kids and
that gave us the energy to keep fighting
for it we had no idea what we're doing
uh but you know between us a lot of our
our friends uh at Annapurna we just kept
fighting to get this movie up and off
the ground and and and luckily we're
here yeah were there moments or elements
in the story that you kind of really
pushed to see added because it does
follow the graphic novel fairly closely
but there are you know story differences
and character differences so were there
beats or elements that you wanted to see
added that maybe weren't in the graphic
novel like yeah yeah there were a couple
things for sure yeah like uh you know in
particular uh the relationship between
baluster and golden loin
um we had to we we wanted to reflect a
little bit more of what we saw in the
world and we also didn't have a full
graphic novel to tell that relationship
because in 10 minutes uh some crazy
stuff was gonna happen in the movie that
would set them apart right so we had to
establish uh true love and
um a real relationship that felt real
that felt grounded because we knew they
were going to try to get back to each
other throughout the movie so that was
that was a big thing that we that was
that's there in the graphic novel but we
wanted to just adjust in less of a
cartoony way and more of a real yeah
abandoned way I think the uh the other
major thing that we felt really strong
about was um
in the graphic novel pneumona and the
shadow creature split to become separate
entities connected and we felt it was
super important to in this adaptation to
keep that singular that that idea that
you can have rough edges you can have
this pain you can lash out you can you
can sometimes show a side of yourself
that is scary or ugly or not what people
want to see but that's okay like all of
that messiness makes us the whole
individual that we are and uh you know
we wanted to make sure that we kept that
that pneumono you know is never
apologetic about it and neither should
we you know there's times when we're
we're great and there's sometimes we're
not at our best but that's okay you know
that's okay we're there like specific
challenges when it came to adapting a
graphic novel I know it maybe feels
easier because it's a hand-drawn Thing
versus animation but were there specific
challenges when it came to making the
adaptation of course yeah I mean like
listen you it's all this that's all
filmmaking is what I guess what were the
challenges yeah no I think I think I
think a thing I'll say more what we were
trying to understand is the sort of Venn
diagram between what ND was creating
when he was creating it how the World
received it right
and and what we wanted to do next with
it to continue to tell that story
um because there there's always what the
author is intending what the connection
is and uh and there was the magic recipe
for us to go forward and again it's just
those themes of acceptance feeling
misunderstood uh particularly connected
with the lgbtq plus Community
um and we wanted just to have one clear
message at the end of all that and that
is just get to know people yeah
and then just make sure all the
technical I mean we're at a point now
with the technology
is just a fun tool to represent all that
right you can do
anything with enough effort and planning
and I think it's represented in the
amazing Cinema that you're seeing in
animation right now
um but for us it was making sure that in
all that fun and all that style it still
came back to the message the story the
characters that you know we were doing
something that the look had a point of
view you know it was this nostalgic
throwback to a fantasy feel but made in
a computer that was technological you
know it's a medieval future type idea so
just making sure all those elements
aren't just there as eye candy or for no
reason but they all have purpose and
they're driving things forward by the
way what an exciting time to be a fan of
Animation I know so many great things
out there that I I like crazy so love
yeah and it's amazing what do you think
it is about animation that just really
resonates because we're like I'm a big
animation fan we are animation fans yeah
a collider what do you think it is about
about the medium I just think it's this
ability to to craft and and and create a
whole world like every element of it
like we get to stylize and bring you
know thought to every frame in a way
that sometimes
um is just a little bit different from
from a live action space I think the
fact that it's it's Artistry
um and you're already opening yourself
up to this idea of this illusion of of
life as it were you so you I think you
open yourself up to the The Narrative
possibilities in a different way
um right from the very beginning because
you you intrinsically just know that
you're you know you're this is a
different
um a different medium for that art form
but it still allows us to tell
incredibly complex and resonant stories
that are that are true to the real world
that were the lit that we're living in
yeah and this is gonna sound weird but I
feel like every real movie you're taking
humans that exist and you're repurposing
them as puppets versus versus animation
every single thing comes from the heart
uh and comes from feeling and it's just
it's it's poetry emotion and I I I I
think that's why we all connect to it is
it feels more real than sometimes the
things that are real